bonjour marième alors le procureur de la
cour pénale internationale on lisait
vient d'effectuer un voyage de trois
jours au venezuela pour se pencher sur
les violations des droits de l'homme
dans ce pays d'amérique latine
dans quel cadre s'inscrit cette visite
mejia bonjour alors la visite du
procureur de la cour pénale
internationale s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'une tournée en amérique latine mais au
venezuela il a été invité par les
autorités vénézuéliennes d'ailleurs il a
rencontré le président nicolas maduro et
d'autres autorités politiques ainsi que
des représentants du pouvoir judiciaire
du corps diplomatique de la société
civile ainsi que des organisations non
gouvernementales
il faut rappeler que le venezuela
souhaité cette rencontre depuis vu
depuis un certain nombre de mois et qui
là que c'est un pays qui a ratifié dès
le départ le statut de rome qui est le
traité international à la source de la
création de la cour pénale
internationale
ouais et et le venezuela qui fait
l'objet d'une enquête préliminaire pour
crimes présumés justement sur ces
manifestations de l'opposition en 2010
est absolument alors c'était une enquête
préliminaire jusqu'à cette nuit où on a
appris là il ya quelques heures que le
procureur karim khan à l'issue de la
visite de trois jours a décidé d'ouvrir
une enquête pour de bon pour les
violations de droits d'homme qui ont eu
lieu lors des manifestations en 2010 est
vous l'avez dit où il avait eu une
centaine de morts dans des
manifestations qui ont dégénéré en
affrontements en émeutes pendant de très
nombreuses semaines une centaine de
morts des victimes qui étaient à
déplorer d'ailleurs de tous les côtés du
côté des manifestants de l'opposition
comme deux des militants chavistes comme
du côté des forces de l'ordre et même
des passants des civils qui passaient
dans la rue qui ont été pris pour cible
la violence avec complètement dégénéré à
ce moment là donc pour le procureur
karim khan il s'agissait de venir
déterminer si les institutions de l'état
vénézuélien fonctionner correctement de
manière à punir les auteurs de ces abus
contre les droits d'âme quand justement
meriem à ce qu'elles fonctionnent
correctement ses institutions alors
c'est en tout cas ce que a voulu et ce
que veut toujours prouvé le gouvernement
vénézuélien qui estime fort avoir fait
le nécessaire et continuer à faire
nécessaires pour punir pour condamner
pour pour passer devant la justice en
fait toutes les personnes impliquées
dans ces crimes
et le procureur général tarek williams à
bâle a déclaré qu' il y avait eu 180 8
condamnations dans le cadre des
violences de 2010 est très récemment un
policier et militaire ont été condamné à
près de 25 ans de prison parce qu'ils
ont été jugés responsables de la mort de
manifestants de l'opposition d'ailleurs
il faut rappeler que le gouvernement
vénézuélien dès 2017 avait dénoncé les
atrocités je cite un commises par par
les membres de la garde nationale
s'étaient dans la bouche de du ministre
de la défense de l'époque vladimir
padrino ça ne suffit pas visiblement
pour pour l'opposition qui vous savez
très très très très comment dire
déterminer au venezuela et qui pour elle
pour elle ces condamnations ne sont
finalement que des gages donnés à la cpi
pour qu'elle nous n'ouvrons pas cette
enquête finalement et bien le procureur
a décidé d'ouvrir cette enquête et nous
verrons s'il est à d'autres
condamnations d'autres responsabilités
déterminées par cette enquête a déçu à
l'issue de ces temps qu'elles ont
apporté d'autres la cpi d'ailleurs qui
qui va se pencher également sur
l'ouverture d'une autre enquête cette
fois demandé par nicholas maduro
lui-même absolument donc le gouvernement
vénézuélien a déposé deux rapports l'un
en février 2020 et l'autre en août de
cette année 2021 visant à ce que la cour
pénale internationale ouvre une autre
enquête cette fois une enquête pour
crimes contre l'humanité perpétrés
contre l'ensemble du peuple vénézuélien
par les sanctions américaines imposées
au venezuela depuis 2014 donc le but des
autorités vénézuéliennes et que cette
enquête soit ouverte et que les etats
unis soient condamnés à cause des
sanctions qu'ils infligent des sanctions
économiques qu'ils infligent au pays je
ne sais pas si maintenant karim khan va
décider d'ouvrir cette enquête ou pas
s'il va l'a jugée pertinente en tout cas
la rapporteur de l'onu
sur sur les effets négatifs des
sanctions sur l'exercice des droits de
l'homme qui s'appelle à l'ena douran est
allé en février de cette année au
venezuela et a estimé que les sanctions
américaines avaient un impact
considérable sur les droits des de la
population vénézuélienne oui merci
beaucoup meriem meriem l'arrivée on peut
retrouver un taux article sur notre site
tâter france est eric naulleau